- People of Gotham, 'tis I, Mark.
Here to relieve you, the little people,
of the burden of wondering
who is the best Batman?
Before I continue, let's make sure that
we're all on the same page.
- There ain't no bat.
- [Mark] You are correct local ruffian.
There isn't one bat, there's been many
bat people over the years.
Batman, Batgirl, even Batboy.
- [Mr. Freeze] Stay cool, bird boy.
- [Mark] But with the recent news that
Robert Pattison will be
filling out the cape and cowl,
we decided it was high time to declare
a greatest Batman of them all.
Your contestants are
Adam West,
Michael Keaton,
Val Kilmer,
George Clooney,
Kevin Conroy,
Christian Bale,
Ben Affleck,
and Will Arnett.
(laughing)
Here's how we'll determine a winner.
Round one, box office.
Round two, Tomatometer.
Round three, most iconic.
And then, we'll do a wild card round.
The crowd is at a fever pitch,
the villains are watching
from Arkham Asylum,
and the Batmen, they're at
home washing their tights.
Let's get it on.
- To the Bat poles.
- Who's your tailor?
- Does it come in black?
(bell clangs)
- [Mark] Round one, box office.
This is going to be an easy win for
one of two possible contenders,
so before we name those
billionaire playboys,
let's take a gander at
some honorable mentions.
Ben Affleck step right up.
You never got a chance to shine
in your very own Batman flick.
Apples which I do not like.
However, he got to play Bats in both
"Batman V. Superman: Dawn of Justice"
and in "Justice League".
Both flicks combined to gross
$593 million domestically
and $1.6 billion worldwide.
Not a bad effort at all,
especially when you consider
that Val Kilmer and George
Clooney's combined outings
grossed $615 million here in the states
and $1.197 billion across the globe.
(crowd cheering)
- Never leave the cave without it.
- [Mark] Unfortunately,
this is a biased category
for TV-friendly Batmen
Adam West and Kevin Conroy.
Their bread was mainly
buttered respectively
on "Batman" the TV series and
"Batman: The Animated Series".
Adam West did get a feature film
but it was just a different time
and I don't have the box office numbers
for the 1966 flick.
Was Lincoln on the penny back then?
- Holy sardines!
- [Mark] And while Kevin
Conroy's Batman has
had two feature films,
they still do the bulk
of their damage on VHS, DVD,
Blu-ray, and streaming sales.
In theaters, his Batman
flicks have done a combined
$16 million internationally.
That's a lot of money
to me but not to Batman.
- What are your superpowers again?
- I'm rich.
- [Mark] In cheerier
animated box office news,
Will Arnett's "Lego
Batman" did $179 million
in the U.S. of A and $312
million over all of Earth.
If you add in his appearances from the two
The Lego Movies, it
brings his worldwide total
haul to an even one billion dollars.
And then, there were two.
- I'm Batman.
- [Mark] This is Keaton
versus Bale all the way.
Bale did a full trilogy,
and Keaton, although he
was reportedly offered
a full dump truck of
100-dollar bills to come back
for a third time, only did "Batman 1989"
and its sequel, the accurately
titled, "Batman Returns".
Bale's "The Dark Knight"
is the highest grossing
flick in the caped crusader's history
getting $698 million domestically
and $1.3 billion worldwide.
In second place, is "Batman
1989" with $590 million
here in the states and $966
million internationally.
All told, Bale's three
movies did $3.945 billion
in total Earth bucks
while Keaton's two talkies
add up to $1.56 billion.
(clapping)
So, why does Keaton win this round?
Well, quite simply if it
weren't for him and his Batman
we wouldn't have any of
these other Batfolk around.
Seriously.
Both his films were massive
hits in way less theaters
than "The Dark Knight" trilogy
and him saying no to a third Batman film
opened the door for our modern world
of quick superhero reinvention.
Val got his chance,
then George,
and George's movie was so
bad it was actually good.
- Why are all the gorgeous
ones homicidal maniacs?
Is it me?
- [Mark] And that we
got to do a total reboot
with a guy named Christopher
Nolan at the helm
which gave us Christian Bale.
I'm so good at explaining stuff.
I should've been a teacher.
Keaton's competitive per movie average
combined with the fact that
it was in less theaters
with less showtimes,
plus the fact that he got there first,
it all adds up to give
him the round one win.
(bell clangs)
Well done, Mikey.
- Alfred, let's go shopping.
- Yes, sir.
(bell clangs)
- [Mark] Round two, Tomatometer.
Unlike the criminals of Gotham City,
moviegoers tend to get excited
when Batman comes around.
But what about the critics?
If Christopher Nolan's
trilogy is to be considered,
the Tomatometer seems to favor the Bat.
Christian Bale's three flicks have
a super fresh average of 88%.
That's gotta be the top
of the mountain, right?
Actually, Will Arnett's
one standalone Bat flick,
"The Lego Batman Movie",
is sitting at 90%.
Plus, the original "Lego Movie" is at 96%.
- Relax everybody, I'm here.
- [Mark] But if we're
going by single Bat-centric
movie accomplishments,
Christian Bale wins out again.
His "The Dark Knight" is the king at 94%.
Ben Affleck's a cool Batman for sure,
but his veggies have turned,
as his two flicks average a rotten 34%.
He's still in good company,
as Val Kilmer's "Batman
Forever" is at 39%.
And maybe we can just
all agree to not even
mention "Batman & Robin"
during this segment.
- Cowabunga!
- [Mark] Michael Keaton's
two flicks average 76%.
And for funsies, guess
which one is higher?
It's "Batman Returns".
That's at 79% while the 1989
reintroduction of Batman
is at 74%.
So, Bale's only real
competition here is with
OG Adam West and Kevin Conroy.
Adam West's one Batman film is at 78%
but if you factor in the TV series,
he leaps all the way up to 85.5%.
Holy B average, Batman!
- Holy hail storm!
- [Mark] Kevin Conroy's
films have a fresh average
of 62% but when you include
the animated shows he's in
he jumps up to 80%.
Good efforts all around.
And for my money, "Justice
League" isn't as bad
as everyone says, you know what
I'm not dying on this hill again.
- At some point even you
have to learn to move on.
- [Mark] When your worst outing as Batman
is at 84% fresh on the Tomatometer
that means two things are true.
Your name is Christian Bale and
(bell clangs)
you just won round two.
Well done.
- It's not who I am underneath
but what I do that defines me.
- Bruce?
(bell clangs)
- [Mark] Round three, most iconic.
Folks, as an icon myself,
I know being iconic
is all about making memorable moments.
Now, a memorable moment isn't always
necessarily a good thing.
Take Val Kilmer, solid Batman,
good brooding Bruce Wayne,
but his most memorable
moment telling Alfred
he'll get drive-through.
- I'll get drive-through.
- [Mark] C'mon, Bruce!
We're already watching your movie,
we're going to Mickey D's after,
don't hit us over the head with it.
- A man's gotta go his own way.
- [Mark] For Michael Keaton,
his most iconic moment
is a tie between a good
one and a crazy one.
In the line that definitively
announced to the world
that there is a new
superhero movie in town,
he grabs a Gotham street
tuff and simply says,
"I'm Batman."
That's how you scare a criminal.
Also seen in "Batman
1989" is Michael Keaton
reverting to his "Beetlejuice"
days when he says
to the Joker--
- Now, you wanna get nuts?!
C'mon, let's get nuts!
- [Mark] What a great
moment for the whole family.
Bring the kids, hell
we got plenty of snakes
and lizards for them to play with.
- What?
- [Mark] Some Batmen had
their best and worst moment
at the same time.
I got two words for you, shark spray.
When a shark is gnawing on Batman's leg
and he's struggling to get
his handy shark repellent
from his utility belt,
it's not only the stupidest thing ever,
it's also a perfect
summation of the campiness
that the original Batman
series was going for.
Christopher Nolan's trilogy
was going for something
darker as evidenced by one
of Bale's classic moments
towards the end of "The Dark Knight".
Rachel!
- Where are they?!
- [Mark] Bale's at his most
iconic when he's straining
his voice so hard as the Caped Crusader
that it borders on insanity.
I'm not wearing hockey pants!
Okay, the Joker interrogation scene
and his escape from Ra's al
Ghul's home for wayward boys
is pretty sweet, too.
- You either die a hero
or you live long enough
to see yourself become the villain.
- [Mark] Speaking of dark, how
about Kevin Conroy's Batman?
Broody-to-the-max and
he's got some killer lines
like in "The Mask of the Phantasm".
- I didn't count on being happy.
- [Mark] Or my personal favorite
from "The Animated Series".
- I am vengeance.
I am the night.
I am Batman!
- [Mark] Woo!
You open with that, it's
an instant swipe right.
Ladies, am I wrong here?
Rounding out the Batfolk,
George Clooney really
only has dull moments.
Will Arnett has some genuinely funny stuff
and is a great study of the Batman pathos,
but the only real contender
here is Ben Affleck.
Ben has a great moment early
on in "Batman v Superman"
when he's running towards danger
as everyone else is fleeing.
Dude really fills out a
Men's Wearhouse vest nicely.
However, by the end of
that flick we're all ready
for the big climax and then what happens?
Martha!
That's what stops you, dude?
You're killing an alien,
you got him on the ropes,
your ma could show up,
"Brucey, stop hurting the poor thing,"
and you'd still finish him off.
C'mon man!
- Don't believe everything you hear, son.
- [Mark] It's a brawl
between Christian Bale
and Michael Keaton for this round
and you know what, it's
actually Kevin Conroy.
That's your winner right here.
Maybe he wasn't on as many magazine covers
when his animated movies came out,
but if we're talking about iconic moments
there's one in practically every episode
of "Batman: the Animated Series",
and every movie he's in is jam-packed with
Bruce Bat's conflict.
With his films and the show,
he had the most opportunity,
the most amount of canvas
with which to paint,
and he gets to go against the
best Joker ever, Mark Hamill.
(bell clangs)
Conroy wins round three.
♪ Am I blue ♪
(bell clangs)
- [Mark] And now it's time
for the wild card round,
the greatest social impact.
Now, this one is gonna Michael Keaton
versus Christian Bale.
Kevin Conroy is great,
West is a legend,
the others had a nice time.
- Oh shit.
- [Mark] But if we're
looking at who influenced
the landscape with their
greatest detective more
it comes down to these two hunks.
Michael Keaton gets some
points for what went down
even before he started shooting.
Once it was announced that
Mr. Mom was gonna be Batman,
people lost their minds.
It was the first time in the modern era
that a true shit was flipped over
a comic book movie casting.
50,000 fans sent in protest letters
hoping to convince Tim Burton
to fire Johnny Dangerously.
And this was before the internet.
You actually had to like write a letter,
and put a stamp on it,
and send it somewhere.
The fans really hated this idea initially,
but then, from opening night on people saw
what a brilliant actor can
do with this role of duality
and Keaton cemented himself as a
versatile A-list movie star.
- I want you to tell all
your friends about me.
- [Mark] "Batman 1989" as a
film was a cultural landmark.
All summer long, it was Batmania.
I know because I lived it.
Did you know there was a
run on black cotton T-shirts
because so many people were buying them up
to make contraband Batman shirts.
I probably owned one or nine.
It ruled the entire year.
And I also remember in the summer of 1992,
a bunch of parents freaking
out because The Penguin
bit a guy's nose and blood
goes gushing everywhere.
So, apparently, parents
were cool with Batman
murdering a gaggle of
killer clowns 20 minutes ago
but a little plasma was over the line.
Ah parenting.
Hope it never happens to me.
Christian Bale steps into
a very different world
than Michael Keaton.
In 2005, audiences were primed and ready
for a darker, grittier type of hero.
And who better to give that
to them than American Psycho.
Patrick Bateman led a double life,
so does Bruce Wayne.
"Batman Begins", aside from
being my personal favorite
comic book film ever, also
helped usher in a new dawn
for the superhero movie.
It was part of a tidal wave
that we're still surfing today.
But it wasn't until "The Dark Knight" that
the social impact was truly felt.
- Why so serious?
- [Mark] "The Dark Knight"
showed movie critics
what fans had hoped for all along.
These kind of movies could
be taken just as seriously
as cinema as any other flick.
It taught us that the term superhero movie
wasn't necessarily a
hindrance to award chances.
In fact, because the source
material was so fantastical
these types of roles
would allow serious actors
to show off their chops
in new, inventive ways.
So, how does one choose between these two,
when both were part of nothing less than
an entire paradigm shift?
Well, because we're looking
at Batman specifically,
and while Christian
Bale was a huge part of
"The Dark Knight" trilogy's greatness,
the lion's share of
praise for these films,
standing head and shoulders
above previous Batman efforts
was thanks to Christopher Nolan.
And it was Heath Ledger's
Joker that led the way
for films like this to
be critically-acclaimed.
So, while Michael Keaton
certainly had help
from the likes of Tim
Burton, Jack Nicholson,
and Michelle Pfeiffer, it
was his genius portrayal
of a tortured soul that
redefined what an audience
would expect from a superhero.
Michael Keaton is a great Bruce Wayne,
an awesome crimefighter,
in short, the best Batman in history.
(bell clangs)
He wins this round and he wins the match.
Yep, that Robert Pattinson
has some big boots to fill.
Be it from any of the previous Batfolk
that had to figure out how to pee
while wearing that cumbersome suit.
Just for some fun, Mark
Hoffmeyer, the Alfred to my Robin,
compiled a bunch of lists
ranking the best Batman
from slew of different polls.
His results show that it's
actually Christian Bale
who takes the mantle as the Bat GOAT
and that Kevin Conroy
is a silver medalist.
Keaton was a close third,
but it just proves, what?
No, it does not prove that I'm a moron.
It proves that our own
opinions matter the most.
So, now it's your turn, dear viewer.
Comment below with the
person who you think
is the best Batman of all time.
Is it Michael Keaton?
Is it Kevin Conroy?
Nicholas Cage as Big Daddy?
Who you got and defend your answer.
And while you're at it, do you think
Robert Pattinson has
the chops to add another
exciting chapter in the Batman legacy?
Remember Pattinson you
are my number one guy.
- [Thomas] All right, have it your way.
- [Mark] That's all from me today.
I'm taking off and I'm a
little hungry but it's okay
I'll get drive-through.
(upbeat music)